bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france ce dispositif est destiné aux
entreprises qui ont un vrai potentiel de
rebond comment est-ce qu'on peut jauger
ce potentiel qui en décidera et bien
justement c'est tout le problème
comment jaugez d'un potentiel de rebond
d'une entreprise c'est a priori les
fonctionnaires de bercy qui vont en
décider je vois pas très bien sur quel
critère
si les entreprises ont des difficultés
de fonds propres certes il faut les
aider dans le contexte actuel c'est très
bien cette idée de les aider mais
comment vont elles être choisi rien n'a
été précisé ça me paraît extrêmement
problématique
alors pour ces prêts participatifs avons
parle de fonds propres des entreprises
ça reste quand même bien une dette à
rembourser est ce que s'est passé allons
ajouter de l'endettement alors nettement
effectivement c'est d'une certaine
manière a ajouté de l'endettement à
l'endettement et qu'on avait déjà avant
la crise du grenat virus à un problème
de dette privée beaucoup trop élevé dans
un certain nombre d'entreprises et au
niveau global au niveau du pays et pas
seulement en france dans notre pays on
la dette privée c'est la première cause
de crise économique
donc il aurait peut-être fallu réfléchir
à d'autres manières d'aider ces
entreprises
peut-être peut-être par des exonérations
temporaires de cotisations sociales
par des mesures leur permettant
d'exercer quand même certaines activités
malgré le confinement etc
c'est très difficile à dire mais en tout
cas là on a un état qui va se mettre à
choisir les entreprises qu'ils
considèrent comme comme solvable les
entreprises non solvable donc je crois
pas très bien sur quel type de critère
on nous a annoncé le retour du plan
alors ça c'est très bien mais est-ce
qu'on va choisir selon les entreprises
écologiques
est-ce qu'on va choisir en fonction de
la taille des entreprises tout ça reste
à préciser reste très flou dans l'état
actuel des choses
alors justement comment comment est-ce
qu'on peut orienter ces fonds de manière
à ce qu'elle contribue à une croissance
durable est ce qu'il n'ya pas là une
occasion aussi à ne pas laisser passer
pour obliger par exemple à une relance
verte à une relance sociale
bah ça aurait été effectivement une
occasion de passer à la transition
écologique mais là on parle de 20
milliards qui vont être distribués aux
entreprises sur des critères qu'on ne
connaît pas moi j'aurais sans doute
cesser c'est nécessaire mais j'aurais
sans doute compléter ce type de mesure à
un moment où emprunter sur les marchés
financiers quasiment gratuits par une
véritable politique publique
d'investissement dans les
infrastructures vertes d'investissement
dans la transition écologique de
d'investissement vers le passage à des
entreprises plus local et le réarmement
de la politique industrielle
ces 20 milliards sont sans doute
nécessaires peut-être même qu'il fallait
mettre plus sur la table
mais il aurait avant tout fallu
réfléchir
finalement au monde d'après
véritablement on entre dans une ère qui
est caractérisée par des eaux dose on va
avoir de plus en plus d'incidents de ce
type il est urgent de réorienter la
politique la politique
économique vers des mesures beaucoup
plus ce qui permet de la transition
écologique qui permettent la
consommation de produits locaux qui
favorise les circuits courts qui
favorise les entreprises solidaires
c'est pas du tout ce qu'on a dans ce
plan alors est ainsi évoqué un label
relance sancerre invité les inciter les
français à investir leur épargne
accumulée pendant la crise lors dé ce
tir dans des pme françaises
ce que vous pensez que ça peut être
efficace c'est une idée qui est plutôt
sympathique dans l'absolu mais vous
savez les entreprises n'ont pas besoin
forcément de lait pain des français pour
pouvoir tourner une entreprise la
première source de financement des
entreprises c'est le prêt bancaire
alors maintenant si les français mettent
leur épargnant les entreprises très bien
mais je ne vois pas pourquoi en général
quand on met son départ dans une
entreprise on ne regarde hélas pu la
couleur de la couleur de l'entreprise ni
son origine géographique on regarde sa
rentabilité et on regarde finalement et
sa rentabilité à très court terme
il aurait peut-être été préférable de
mettre en place des incitations pour
pousser les personnes entre investir
dans des entreprises françaises à
investir dans du long coeur merci pour
votre regard belle et longue maître de
conférences en économie à l'université à
paris trêve si vous